don't forget we're the bad guys people  just industrial about freaking out are  you getting at all the time yeah you  know it's um it's just one of those  things that when it hits a court and you  just have no idea why it's really  exciting what a jaded think if you're  dead shot costume oh no she thought it  was pretty hot I went with the the show  tonight look that was my youth I was  using my model you know so I went with  that ruff ruff ruff rugged and raw so  she appreciated that why is this gonna  be the movie the summer Suicide Squad  it's really different you know it's it's  uh it's it's funny I think it's a thinks  one of those films that that hits on all  cylinders no hard feelings right we good